Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Henry Giroux, who is the chaired professor
of scholarship in the public interest at McMaster
University.
His most recent book is Race, Politics and
Pandemic Pedagogy, published this year by
Bloomsbury.
It's so great to have you on.
I appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: Oh, I'm delighted to be here.
Speaker 1: So, you know, there's been many
political analyzes made of this authoritarian
slide that we've seen that we could say led
up to the election of Donald Trump in 2016,
but then also was further fomented by the
election of Donald Trump in 2016.
I'm interested to hear from you more, your
thoughts on the cultural aspect of this and
how far back you think the the kind of catalysts
for this slide go and how we should sort of
be conceiving of it.
Speaker 4: I mean, I think we've seen political
and cultural extremism in the United States.
It has a long history.
I mean, we've seen it with the McCarthy period.
We saw with the Red Scare.
And then, of course, there's the legacy of
colonization.
I mean, there's the wiping out of indigenous
populations.
There's Jim Crow, there's slavery.
And I think that one of the things that this
country has failed to confront is not only
that legacy, but how it tends to reappear
in different forms in different historical
moments.
And I think that where I see an enormous turning
point in the United States is in the 1970s,
all of a sudden, it seems to me there's there's
a counter-revolution emerging against the
60s, against the democratization of the social
order, against the attempt to in some way
eliminate massive inequalities in wealth and
power.
And with Reagan, something happens.
And what happens is there's an enormous shift
in cultural values.
And that shift moves away from supporting
the public good to basically, in many ways,
destroying it and claiming that the market
now should be the template not simply for
judging the economy or managing the economy,
but for all of social life.
This has an enormously destructive consequence,
it seems to me, in the United States.
And it begins to give rise to far right wing
movements, who, for the most part, hate the
public good, hate the common good, and all
of a sudden find themselves on the side of
reproducing echoes of history that are pretty
dangerous, whether we're talking about right
wing extremism, racial purity, misogyny, militarism,
ultra nationalism.
I mean, all these forces begin to come in
to become very visible and come to the surface
in light of the increasing misery that I call
neo liberalism or gangsta capitalism produces.
As a result of the 1980s,
Speaker 1: when I when I spoke to Noam Chomsky
a couple of months ago, the political points
that he thought were relevant in that period
you're talking about include as a reaction
to the civil rights movement, the established
the establishment of the war on drugs, for
example, the fight against Roe v. Wade, and
that some of these points led to what the
Republican Party became in the early 90s under
Newt Gingrich.
And then we can sort of like follow the political
line.
Culturally, though, what was it about those
things that were happening prior to during
and after the 70s that kind of changed this
American right wing?
Speaker 4: I mean, what you begin to see culturally,
a couple of things.
Ideologically, you see the ideology of self-interest
reproduced in many ways and celebrity culture
and consumerism.
Citizenship takes on a very different form
culturally after the 1980s.
All of a sudden, the obligations of citizenship
citizenship have to do with consumerism.
The more becomes the temple of the state,
so to speak.
But you also see something else.
You see a rise of what I call the punishing
state and a decline of the social state.
And with that comes a number of cultural apparatuses
that begin to reinforce what I call the most
insidious cultural aspect of neo liberalism
or gangster capitalism.
And that is the individualization of problems.
Everything becomes privatized.
All problems are a matter of individual responsibility.
And what that means culturally is it becomes
increasingly difficult for people to translate
private troubles into larger systemic considerations.
So the social begins to collapse.
Now, what happens as a result of that?
Culturally, what happens is you have the war
on drugs.
You have, of course, Clinton's war in the
welfare state.
You have the Southern strategy.
I mean, all of things, all of these things
combine a question of racial purity and what
I call white supremacy with the logic of capitalism.
Somebody has to be blamed and who has to be
blamed by immigrants or blacks or young people.
You know, all those groups that are relative.
Powerless in the face of this overwhelmingly
political and cultural apparatus.
Now, David, there's something else, and I
think the other side of this is what we have
to understand is that education takes a radical
turn.
In the 1980s, it increasingly becomes privatized,
commodified, undermined, defunded.
And all of a sudden, we're not talking about
educating people to be critical, engaged citizens
anymore.
We're talking about them.
We're talking about teachers to teach for
the test.
Yep.
Yes.
Runs through a whole range of presidents.
I mean, the Republican and the Democratic
parties both share a notion of education,
is anti intellectual, destroys the civic imagination
and imposes what I call a pedagogy of repression
and basically produce increases of anti intellectualism
that is in the schools and in the larger cultural
apparatus.
Right.
Second point, don't confuse schooling with
education.
That's it.
Schooling is an institution that we know of
public higher, but education takes place in
other spheres.
The new social media, the digital media, the
rise of what I call an Iraqi image based culture.
And these are largely controlled by the right.
And so you have this tsunami of anti intellectualism,
right wing nonsense, lies, misinformation,
conspiracy theories emerging since the 1970s.
And you find their end point and Trump.
Speaker 1: Well, I want to get back to the
education piece because I have so many notes
about it.
One small thing that I was thinking of in
your cultural idea of the kind of individualization
of problems, is this related to the gun issue
in the United States in this specific sense
that unlike in many other countries, too many
people in the U.S. see guns as a way to solve
problems that are that are really systemic
problems.
But they say I will solve individually this
problem with a firearm.
Speaker 4: I think it's a brilliant analysis
and I think it's right on target.
I think that basically when you individualize
problems, you say that people have to take
both responsible for those problems individually
and have the right to engage them in ways
that suggest that the government is the enemy
of freedom rather than something that could
be useful in dealing with these issues.
The other side of this is that when you individualize
problems in this way, you can't address them
systemically.
So you begin to increasingly criminalize social
problems.
So, you know, if you, for instance, acting
out in schools, you know, the principal doesn't
come down and say, hey, come on, let's talk.
You call the police and all of a sudden you
have little five year olds in handcuffs in
kindergarten.
So it seems to me with this increasing criminalization
of social problems, you have a notion of freedom
emerging that is completely removed from any
notion of social responsibility, religious
freedom that simply says I can do what I want.
Self-interest is all that matters.
All problems are individualized.
This is what I call the individualization
of the social and the social sphere and the
social contract and the social good and the
public good.
David, begin to collapse.
We lose those sites where people can understand
the interconnections that make a democracy
possible.
Couple that with an education and schooling
system that basically produces new forms of
civic illiteracy.
And you don't have a democracy anymore because
you can't have a democracy without informed
citizens.
Speaker 1: So on education, I frequently will
get calls from viewers.
I mean, listen, talking about individualizing
things, I will get calls from viewers who
say, my cousin, my uncle, whoever, they've
fallen for false beliefs about vaccines.
They've fallen for false beliefs about it
doesn't matter what.
But they're not thinking.
They've just they've fallen for it.
How do I talk them out of it?
And I struggle to say anything other than,
you know, at the individual level, it can
take weeks or months of really getting someone
to reexamine their beliefs.
That's like a retail strategy.
It's not a wholesale strategy.
My instinct is it's too late.
And and really, if people learned critical
thinking and media literacy and epistemology
in middle school, we prevent this from even
happening in the first place to some degree,
not with everybody, but maybe we give people
the tools to not fall into this in the first
place.
Is that a fair critique of of at least a piece
of what's wrong with the educational or schooling
system, as you call it today?
Speaker 4: No, I think it's an important piece.
I mean, it's foundational and that the way
we educate people says something about the
kind of agents we produce and the kind of
future we want.
And it seems to me education and schooling
in that sense is very long term.
I think the other side of this is that, you
know, how do we talk about taking control
of these cultural apparatuses that basically
this imagination machines?
I mean, we're not just talking about how do
you say it?
The ability to get people to think critically
or rationally or to be able to engage are
the positions that's important.
But.
We're also talking about larger systemic apparatuses
that need to be challenged by people like
us in social movements and reproduced in ways
that give people the opportunity to be able
to recognize that the most fundamental questions
are not whether they're falling for lies,
but what kind of future do they want for their
children?
Do they want health care that's free?
Do they want to be in debt for the rest of
their lives?
Critical consciousness matters, but it has
to translate.
Ideas have to translate and be wedded to power.
And it seems to be when we removed the question
of power from the question of insight, we
fall into a trap that we unconsciously reproduce
that we may want to stay away from.
And that is to say, we'll just talk to each
other.
No, I'm sorry.
It's not about just right.
It's about changing the very institutions
that have put us there in the first place.
And that's not just a burden of people who
are confused.
That's that's a political obligation that
we all have to engage in with those people,
hopefully.
Speaker 1: So in that sense, I mean, when
when you hear these very superficial narratives
of part of the problem is left and right,
don't engage anymore or the dialog has coarsened
this type of stuff, is does that not really
strike you as particularly important?
Speaker 4: That's a diversion.
And I find that as a political diversion because
it doesn't deal with fundamental questions
like, look, what's the result of massive inequality
in the United States and where does it come
from?
Right.
Is it what does it mean when some people are
trading medicine for for for, you know, for
food stamps?
You know, what does it mean when schools are
collapsing?
You know, that's not a matter of whether the
right and left can show up to each other.
That's a matter of how do we talk about democracy
as a country if we're going to take democracy
seriously?
And what are the forces that are undermining?
These are very different kinds of questions.
What does it mean to live in a country where
economic activity is removed from social cost?
What's the consequence of that and how does
it bring it down on our lives?
The last thing is that we have to be able
to shame is a terrible pedagogical tool.
I think shaming people does nothing but just
reinforce the worst divisions.
And I think the real question here for all
of us is how do we begin to use a language
in which people can recognize themselves,
in which we can shift consciousness, in ways
in which people can say, yeah, that's that
makes sense to me without putting their identities
on trial.
We need a language rigorous, accessible in
order to make something meaningful, to make
it critical, to make a transformative.
Speaker 1: Can you give an example of that
in terms of on any issue, could you give an
example of the wrong way that the language
is being used and then how it could be improved?
Speaker 4: I mean, I think in talking to people
that, for instance, dealing with schools because
the schools are failing, it's terrible.
I think we should homeschool.
And one of the questions I always raise is
that if school is so crucial, do you think
school is crucial to democracy, to your life,
for your children?
Yes.
Then why is it being defunded?
Schools aren't failing, they're being defunded.
I mean, the problem is not that schools are
failing.
The problem is that they actually serve a
very important purpose in society.
We have to ask ourselves, why do people want
to destroy them and why do some people have
access that you don't?
What can we do to make schools matter in your
community?
How would we do that together?
How would we speak to that?
How would we make schools more?
Richard, what resources do we need?
What policies?
What does it mean to get on a school?
What can we do that in order to change a curriculum
so that you have, for instance, free meals
for your kid in the morning?
Kids starving can't learn.
Sorry, you know, right.
About 47 kids in a class can't learn.
So I think what we start to deal with particulars
and make them resonate with the very conditions
that people could recognize in their lives.
We make something meaningful to make it.
Well, I'll give you one last example.
People often say to me, why don't you come
to the United States, come back?
And I say, well, would you get national health
care?
And so what do you mean, I say, look, I've
had two knee surgeries I haven't paid.
I don't pay a penny.
A cent, you know, my drugs are basically free.
I can walk into a corner doctor's office,
a drop in center and get free medical care.
And they don't believe this stuff.
And, you know, when I say, you know, most
debt in the United States is now due to medical
expenses.
Right.
I mean, you know what I know just recently,
one hospital, I think, in Tennessee charged
somebody six thousand seven hundred fifty
dollars for three tests for coronavirus.
You know, this this sort of thing has to be
talked about and illustrated and then in some
way connected to people's lives
Speaker 1: in terms of the language that we're
seeing to sort of shift back a little bit
to our to the earlier part of the conversation.
Federico Finkelstein from the New School,
regularly, a fellow Argentinean, I might add.
He has written a lot about the analagous language
between, you know, past authoritarians and
dictators and the kind of modern language
of Trump, et cetera.
Two part question.
One, to what degree do you see the language
as analogous?
And two, are these politically astute comparisons
to be making from a practical perspective,
even if they are true?
Speaker 4: I think they're absolutely practical.
And I know his work and I know him and I and
I think that if we can't learn from the past,
as the old saying goes, we're more than doomed
to repeat it.
We might we might find ourselves in places
that we never could have imagined could happen.
We might find ourselves faced with the unthinkable.
And I think that when we talk about ultranationalism,
we talk about militarism.
I mean, we talk about, for instance, the 1930s
in the 40s.
One of the things that we have to make clear
is simply because factually what I call fascist
politics emerges but doesn't present itself
in an exact replica does not mean it doesn't
exist.
It means that it's always in remission, but
tends to emerge in different forms.
And I think that what we have to look at is
the signals.
We have to look at the similarities.
And certainly he's absolutely right, as is
Timothy Snyder, Jason Stanley and a number
of others who are saying, hey, look, look
at this language lies how central with the
question of lies.
And, for instance, in the Nazi regime, racial
purity, racial cleansing.
What does that tell us?
Where did that go?
In the 1930s and 40s, the appeal to militarism
hypermasculinity the attack on women's bodies,
the attack on others, the friend enemy distinction,
the the the ongoing attempt to demonize people
and to claim that the public sphere is only
for white people.
My God.
I mean, if that doesn't conjure up an image
of the past and echoes of the past that we
should take seriously, then the thought that
if you believe if you don't believe in that
analysis, you're going to have to end up in
a cell somewhere before you actually realize.
Right, a fascist politics is here alive, well
and thriving.
Think about the January six attack.
I mean, even Robert Patterson, who first was
a great historian of fascism, who said, no,
Trump is not a fascist, has come out recently
and said, I was wrong.
I'm sorry, the line has been crossed.
We are basically now in a fascist culture
and fascist politics is on the rise of the
United States and represents a very dangerous
moment.
Speaker 1: The latest book from Henry Giroux
is Race, Politics and Pandemic Pedagogy, published
by Bloomsbury.
We've been speaking with Henry, who chaired
Professor for Scholarship in the Public Interest
at McMaster University.
It's been so great having you on.
I can't tell you how much I appreciate your
time today.
Speaker 4: Oh, thank you, David.
It's a pleasure.